nos dicen la tabla siguiente y con lo
que la tabla a la izquierda para que
todos nos queden una sola pantalla la
tabla siguiente muestra los resultados
de un estudio observacional del 2007 con
los cumpleaños de los jugadores en el
equipo del campeonato amateur canadiense
de hockey juvenil compases los
resultados de su estudio cuáles de las
siguientes conclusiones son válidas en
la tabla podemos ver a los distintos
jugadores
este es el jugador número 9 cuya fecha
de nacimiento es el 4 de enero de 1988
el jugador número 16 nació el 10 de
enero de 1987 así que tenemos la fecha
de nacimiento de todos los jugadores del
equipo y nos preguntan cuáles de las
siguientes conclusiones son válidas
1 hay una asociación entre los jugadores
que estuvieron en el equipo del
campeonato amateur y canadiense de
hockey juvenil del 2007 y que el día de
su nacimiento se encuentre entre el
primero de enero y el 30 de junio en su
respectivo año muy bien en el número 1
nos piden que pensemos en una relación
es decir una asociación entre la fecha
de nacimiento y la probabilidad de estar
en el equipo número 2 no hay asociación
entre los jugadores que estuvieron en el
equipo del campeonato amateur canadiense
de hockey juvenil del 2007 y que su día
de nacimiento se encuentre entre el
primero de enero y el 30 de junio en su
respectivo año ok
número 3 los jugadores de hockey
canadienses nacidos en 1987 son más
propensos a ser jugadores profesionales
que los nacidos en 1989
número 4 más jugadores del equipo del
campeonato amateur canadiense de hockey
juvenil del 2007 nacieron en 1987 que en
cualquier otro año ok lo que nos piden
es trabajar con una asociación ya sea
entre su fecha de nacimiento y la
primera mitad del año o entre su año de
nacimiento no nos piden asociar solo con
enero y febrero nos piden comparar con
la mitad del año o comparar un año con
otro así que graphic hemos nuestros
datos
hagamos una historia ma tenemos las
fechas de nacimiento a partir de 1987
hasta 1989
así que pensemos en las dos mitades de
cada año vamos a partir del primer mes
de 1987 hasta el sexto mes de 1987
aquí pondremos a los jugadores que
nacieron en la primera mitad de 1987
después tendremos del séptimo mes de
1987 hasta el doceavo mes de 1987 aquí
pondremos a los jugadores que nacieron
en la segunda mitad de 1987 después
tendremos desde el primer mes de 1988
hasta el sexto mes de 1988 la primera
mitad de 1988 bien y después tenemos la
segunda mitad de 1988 del séptimo mes
hasta el doceavo mes de 1988 haremos lo
mismo para 1989 tendremos desde el
primer mes de 1989 hasta el sexto mes de
1989 y después tenemos la segunda mitad
de 1989 del séptimo mes hasta el doceavo
mes de 1989
ahora veamos cuántos jugadores hay en
cada grupo en el primer grupo es decir
en la primera mitad de 1987 tenemos al
jugador 16 que nació en enero de 1987 en
color morado al jugador 14 que nació en
enero de 1987 al jugador 3 que nació en
marzo de 1987 y al jugador 10 que nació
en mayo de 1987 son 4 jugadores por lo
que pondré 4 puntos ahora veamos en la
segunda mitad de 1987 tenemos dos
jugadores 1 y 2
1 y 2 y ahora pensemos en 1988 en la
primera mitad tenemos 1 2 3
cuatro tenemos cuatro jugadores en la
primera mitad de 1988 ok
en la segunda mitad no tenemos a ningún
jugador por último tenemos un jugador en
la primera mitad de 1989 en marzo de
1989 y son todos los jugadores puedes
ver que en 1987 de manera
desproporcionada
hubo más jugadores que nacieron en la
primera mitad que la segunda esto no es
cierto para toda la población si
pensamos en la población mundial aunque
no sé bien los datos pero espero que
tenga una distribución más uniforme
podemos ver que todos los jugadores que
nacieron en 1988 nacieron en la primera
mitad del año 10 1989 solo tenemos un
jugador que nació en la primera mitad
del año así que veamos de nuevo las
opciones
número 1 hay una asociación entre los
jugadores que estuvieron en el equipo
del campeonato amateur canadiense de
hockey juvenil del 2007 y que su día de
nacimiento se encuentre entre el primero
de enero y el 30 de junio en su
respectivo año bueno si parece cierto
parece que de manera desproporcionada
hay más jugadores que nacieron en la
primera mitad del año así que me gusta
esta conclusión y puedes verlo en el
histograma en 1987 hay una desproporción
en la primera mitad
en 1988 todos nacieron en la primera
mitad al igual que en 1989
número 2 no hay asociación entre los
jugadores que estuvieron en el equipo
del campeonato amateur canadiense de
hockey juvenil del 2007 y que société
nacimiento se encuentre entre el primero
de enero y el 30 de junio en su
respectivo año bueno ya podemos cancelar
esta opción no puedes seleccionar ambas
conclusiones ya que sólo una puede ser
verdadera número 3 los jugadores de
hockey canadienses nacidos en 1987
son más propensos a ser jugadores
profesionales que los nacidos en 1989
bueno no estamos hablando de jugadores
profesionales estamos hablando del
equipo canadiense de hockey juvenil así
que no creo que debamos hacer una
conclusión sobre la probabilidad de que
un jugador se convierta en profesional
una vez más la única razón del por qué
tienes más jugadores nacidos en 1987 que
en 1989 se debe a que estamos trabajando
con el equipo juvenil de un solo año
particular y en un año particular es
normal tener más jugadores con una edad
mayor que jugadores de menos edad pero
en dos años el equipo que juega el
campeonato tendrá muchos jugadores
nacidos en 1989 que ya habrán madurado
así que en definitiva no podemos decir
nada sobre jugadores profesionales de
hockey ya que estamos trabajando con el
equipo juvenil
bien y número 4 más jugadores del equipo
del campeonato amateur canadiense de
hockey juvenil del 2007 nacieron en 1987
que en cualquier otro año bueno estos
datos son del 2007 y puedes ver que en
efecto el campeonato amateur canadiense
de hockey juvenil tiene más jugadores de
1987 que de cualquier otro año tenemos 6
jugadores nacidos en 1987 contra 4
jugadores nacidos en 1988 y solo un
jugador nacido en 1989
así que seleccionaremos este número 4
como una conclusión verdadera recuerda
todo esto es un trabajo pensado en el
2007 todo esto cambiará para el equipo
en el 2008 y en el 2009 etcétera así que
me agradan las conclusiones 1 y 4 por lo
que seleccionar la opción que dice 1 el
4 y hemos acabado